hey guys welcome to ask IJ this is a
very special episode because I have a
very special guest a very special this
is this is cats Caspari
meet Casper the cutest freaking pig ever
I'm so excited guys as most of you guys
know it it is like my dream to have a
pig I follow like 50 pigs on Instagram
now I'm gonna answer some of your
questions parallel sky is asking if the
pig prefers Mac or PC
are you more of a PC or a Mac user what
do you think definitely Mac user for
sure Maddy is asking if there were
purple pigs would I get one I mean this
is the most perfect bag like when I saw
this pig at my front door like actually
came to my front door I was like this is
perfect look at it it's beautiful
because I cry almost cries I'm so
excited I'll be hungry you think those
little snacks on aren't you know compute
come back come back we have to snack for
you welcome here thank you
good this is for you
good pig good piggy now you stay here
I'll give you another one thank you um
Devante wants to know how I plan to stop
the consumption of bacon and I'm come
here come here
I actually stopped eating meat because I
love Pig so much and I don't make
anymore you want more snacks hold up
wait a minute I got something for you
because I don't need your kind anymore
so you should like me um Laurie wants to
know what's with the pigs well Laurie I
don't know they're just so cute and so
sweet
Hale oh my god I would love it's like
the best day of my life when everyone
sighs to see will the best day of your
life I'm going to just send you this
link because this is the best day ever
oK we've got one more little question
for you actually got a couple for Mikey
J wants to know girl pig boy pig howls
it polishes away does it know any tricks
it does know a lot of tricks we've been
doing tricks all day
good I got for you we're good I am you
know you want it you know you want it we
were doing kisses earlier
can you do a little give you a little
circle or something oh that's my rib
flash my red pig
circle hey no more naughty to save here
heat up time I'm dying inside okay your
stay here we all more questions
it's year old I am witches away wait 8
Wow thank about feet up and I showed you
the trick so I answer all your questions
would you call piggie Mr piggy or star
pupils is that this is a Miss Piggy if I
had five pigs come back come back
feed up over here feed up over here good
girl cook oh you know I'm a nice nice
watch okay here you go that's for being
such a good little pig now come back up
feet up um if I had five pigs what would
you name them that's too much I can't
think about that right now
come back my god would you rather be a
pig or be able to read pigs mind and not
talk to them what does I don't know what
you're asking but I'm just I would want
to be a pig like I want right like when
I think about myself like this this is
where I want to be like I just want to
be sitting around just chillin eating
stuff off the ground we shot I was doing
a little shot at the front door and
there's I was eating pizza and there
were single Pizza droppings and gets you
Xena Lanisha
the little piggy play video games with
it and show him your videos if I owned a
pig what would you name it come here
Casper Casper come here
okay Casper here go whoops
so that's gotta go the video a spur come
here I forgot what the question is I'm
so sad drive if I owned a pickle what I
named it I would name it Jamie so I've
already decided this so
look how oh my on your face um that's
all the questions that I have I'm so
happy right now
hey Casper come back here alright guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this video because I am
having the time of my life right now
don't forget to subscribe and please if
you like this video click like do it for
Casper because she will be so happy
so happy I hope you had as much fun as I
did did you have fun guess not
okay be free be free ticky